alright it gives me no pleasure to
report to you today that I was 100%
correct about what we were going to see
out of the Democratic primary on
Medicare for all I told you that in the
2020 Democratic primary Medicare for all
would sort of be a litmus test you would
have to pay lip service to something
sounding like Medicare for all but we
were going to see I predicted the more
centrist and corporate Democrats handle
it in the form of I would love Medicare
for all and I support the idea here's
how I would tweak Obamacare or improve
the system we have and I'm open to all
options but sure Medicare for all sort
of sounds nice paying lip service but
really focusing on other policies as the
starting point for health care and just
within hours of her CNN Town Hall
Democratic candidate Kamala Harris has
done exactly that I'm picking on her
here because she was the first to do it
others will do it this is not a
particular attack only on Kamala don't
worry
others are going to do this as well
let's set it up Monday night Kamala has
a town hall on CNN she immediately makes
huge headlines at this town hall saying
we may not even need private insurers
period because she supports Medicare for
all period bottom line check this out
from the town hall what is your solution
to ensure that people have access to
quality health care at an affordable
price and does that solution involve
cutting insurance companies as we know
them out of the equation
I believe the solution and I'm and I'm
actually feel very strongly about this
is that we need to have Medicare for all
that's just the bottom line
and I'll say this and this is I think
while you're also asking this question
what we know is that to to live in a
civil society to be true to the ideals
in the spirit of who we say we are as a
country Wow
so how progressive she's saying all the
right things except that within 24 hours
after taking criticism from the usual
suspects she is starting to back off and
an advisor of hers put out a statement
saying you know she's actually open to
much more moderate ideas as well like
preserving the industry we have but just
making tweaks and just like that before
a single ballot has been cast before a
single Democratic primary debate has
even been scheduled she's negotiating
with herself without anybody having done
anything and this requires a lot of
analysis so let's start here do we
actually believe that any candidate who
says I'm for Medicare for all is going
to get Medicare for all passed merely
because they support it of course not
okay
Medicare for all would be a massive
undertaking you're going to need the
White House you're going to need the
House and Senate you're going to need to
phase it in over time even if you do
you're not going to in any immediate
sense eliminate private health insurance
private health insurance will be allowed
to exist if people want it they can go
to it so why then before a single vote
has been cast her before a single word
has been spoken at a Democratic primary
debate
why is she already backing off and
saying I want Medicare for all but I'm
open merely to tweaking the system that
we have she's negotiating against
herself this signals weakness the other
thing that's really important to
remember because I'm focusing now on
Kamala since she's the one who first
softened her position but others are
going to do it to remember that the
Democratic Party platform is not
Medicare for all okay you go to the
Democratic party platform website they
say that they want secure universal
health care okay what they mean by that
when you look at the details is they
want to secure universal health care
meaning that everybody has access to
health care by lowing lowering Medicare
access to
55 Plus as an opt-in and by putting in
place a public option those are definite
improvements to the system that we have
right now but that's not medicare for
all or anything close to it okay so it's
really important that we all understand
when a Democratic candidate says I'm for
Medicare for all that's not the
Democratic platform and even though we
are going to see all of the candidates
pay lip service
it's a medicare-for-all we're going to
need to do more digging and probing to
see well what exactly do they mean by
that Democrats need to be asked when
they say I like Medicare for all
mr. or MS candidate the Democratic the
Democratic platform is not Medicare for
all it's public option plus Medicare opt
in at 55 years of age do you disagree
with the Democratic platform and believe
that it should be changed to say we
support Medicare for all or are you more
of the mindset that Medicare for all
might be nice in some general future
sense but you are with the Democratic
Party's position on this issue because
we've got to figure out how actually
committed they are to this thing Pat and
of course understanding that they just
can't be elected snap their fingers and
put in Medicare for all there is no
reason for the negotiation to be
happening now before there's even any
debate to be had yeah I don't want to
hear Medicare for all is the goal I
don't even want to hear we need Medicare
for all I want them to go a step further
and say I'm going to fight tooth and
nail to ensure that every American gets
Medicare you know I wanted to be that
strong and this is kind of overlapping
with the conversation that we had 10
years ago during the last major
healthcare debate Barack Obama started
with the position that we should have
the Affordable Care Act plus the public
option he didn't quite have the votes
for that and then had to negotiate down
and eventually we got the Affordable
Care Act that we all know about if he
had started with Medicare for all back
then maybe now we'd have a public option
maybe now we'd be in a better spot and I
think it's important that you don't
start negotiating with yourself because
hey you're going to end up with
something better if you don't do that
that's exactly right and and you know we
don't have to we're not pretending to be
naive here right nobody thinks that just
because the president supports Medicare
for all we're going to get Medicare for
all but the negotiations should start
there start the negotiation in a
position of strength and and actual
alignment with what the American people
want which is Medicare for all or
something like it and then we all know
that if you don't have the House and
Senate or if any other number of
situations present themselves you will
of course have no choice but to end up
negotiating and any reasonable person
would support an improvement over the
current system as an initial step but to
already be softening on this issue to me
signals that's not a candidate that I'm
interested in supporting she's the first
there will be others who will do the
same thing and we're going to hold them
accountable for it I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman send me your thoughts the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a great
service that i use all the time what
they do is they take thousands of the
most popular non-fiction books including
the newest bestsellers they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst I recently checked
out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
Jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on blinka they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I'm putting a
link in the video description and after
the free trial if you'd like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa k